the gyro can experience American that a
nation of immigrants I don't like that
language overlooks indigenous peoples
and involuntary implements like black
people and and and slavery was not
America's original sin that's another
neoliberal lie that you hear all the
time on the corporate media's if
indigenous peoples suffering has to be
rendered invisible highlight black
people what's one of the least discussed
in justices of this nation and then
their current situation with their in
these reservations with extreme
alcoholism they still got the rich music
and poetry and resistant but the the
social conditions are just but this they
are the casualties of a settler colonial
enterprise and we'd rather act as if
they don't exist I mean we black people
became central because our labor and our
imagination and culture became central
and we had a ball-bearing civil war
750,000 people day in each life precious
and that has been the central event in
the shaping of America so when people
talk about race they go straight to
blackness as if indigenous peoples in
redness not integral to it's just that
they've been rendered so invisible and
the vicious attack has been so immense
what's so complicated too that they have
their own rules on the reservations
they're allowed to have gambling and
they can have all sorts of they they
have their own sovereignty in a certain
way on the reservations is very odd oh
no it's true and I was blessed to be
there in Standing Rock on a couple of
December's ago it was one of the
marvelous moments in my life to stand
there with the the group there was a
multiracial group people came from all
around the world and I am inclined from
Canada for the most part it was a matter
of the indigenous peoples coming
together memories of Wounded Knee in
1890 over 400 people did you remind
people with this with Stanley Roberts my
standing around was a struggle over that
Piper's right absolutely trying to put
pressure on the Obama administration to
ensure that a pipeline was not built
that would violate the sacred lands and
many of the sacred memory
of indigenous peoples and it was
magnificent because you had two coming
together of indigenous nations because
part of the problem is true for whole
oppressed people is fighting among
themselves and the difficulty of coming
together the first time you had to
coming together a significant number of
indigenous peoples nations unified
against the greedy corporate elites who
were trying to promote this pipeline
through Canada all the way down to the
southern section of the United States
and there was his stuff well we first
one we got an announcement right where
we were there it was freezing tomb it
was December and they were hosing people
down - oh Lord
they were hosing people down wet and
wetting them down while this is going on
it was about - 15 or whatever it was it
was freezing up there you know and but
know what we got an announcement from
the Obama administration for a
suspension of it because they had plan
to do it - I mean you know Obama
administration can be very accommodating
to Wall Street interests and corporate
elite interests and so forth even given
the image and spectacle of a black
president being a progressive and
what-have-you much more progressive to
Trump that that's not saying too much
right but but we got a suspension and
and the struggle continues really but it
was it and it has sent tremendous
ripples through the cultures of
indigenous peoples and their nations in
terms of coming together and the fact
that it was successful absolutely and
there was at least a relative victory
yeah all these victories a relative but
very relative victory it was beautiful
just to see again you you know you can't
downplay the role of joy don't brother
this is so very important - joy in
struggle the joy in organising - joy in
fighting for justice the joy in the
nightclubs the joy and the churches and
mosques temples and synagogues joy is
something that we need to come back to
that's one of the great secrets of the
human conditions what are the sources of
joy what are the conditions for the
possibility of joy we've been
sets with pleasure for the last a
hundred years or so and there's nothing
wrong with with pleasure but pleasures
not the same thing as joy you know when
you look at the sparkling eyes of your
precious daughter
that's not pleasure that's joy hmm you
and your wife that's deep deep joy
see that's what endures you could be
broke as the Ten Commandments
financially but that memory will bring
you joy
[Applause]